the plugged in betas are basically about
80 of men out there it's blissful
ignorance if that makes sense
um
they just kind of sleepwalk through life
uh these are the blue pill guys
um they're not getting the their their
best results out of life they're not
really living a optimized fulfilled life
but this is the vast majority of the
male population right now when they when
they deal with women they're for the
most part plugged in betas okay
um
they've been the need of women and
society's narratives uh so the happy
wife happy life narrative uh you know
put her on a pedestal um now when i say
put put her on a pedestal it's not just
in life but you'll also see this in in
in social media was one of the points
that i made over here which i'm going to
expand on
in later content but what that looks
like is you'll see it on places like um
facebook probably for the most part or
instagram or twitter um but on the main
socials where
the relationship you know description is
broken down in there and they're talking
about how
oh she's my you know she's my one i
would be nothing without her if it
wasn't for her blah blah my life was
nothing until she entered it you know
the standard sort of stuff and they're
constantly at anniversaries valentine's
day birthdays
kids at her kids graduation even just
random events putting her up on a
pedestal and the one thing that you'll
notice and
this is part of the unplugging process
the one thing that you'll notice is
she generally doesn't reciprocate so
try this if you don't trust me go and
try this yourself you know you'll see
one of your plugged in friends and
they're going to go on about you know
they'll have some picture of her you
know with him leaning in looking like
all plugged in beta plugged out and
she's staring at the camera with a big
you know smile on her face and he's
staring at her kissing her on the cheek
um you know you've all seen pictures
like that and it's got some caption in
it about how she's the best thing ever
and he'd be nothing without her and then
you click her profile and there's
nothing it's crickets it's sometimes
it's even worse than crickets it's like
pictures of her
on instagram posing in bikinis you know
soliciting the attention of other guys
and there's nothing covering him or you
know
basically reciprocating his feelings for
her but back the other way on her social
feed so that's what that looks like um
i'll talk about that a little bit more
you know another cast you know to be
more specific on it these these plugged
in betas they're they're the guys you
know it's 80 of the population that are
chasing women not excellence
um
they'll they'll do whatever it'll it'll
take just to get the girl
but they won't put themselves first they
won't
figure out how to make serious bank they
won't figure out how to level themselves
up in all areas that they might be
deficient in okay so these are the guys
that are chasing women but not
excellence they're mostly nice guys
and one of the things that you'll notice
that they'll do
um go and sign up for some of these like
you know facebook groups like these
private groups like you know the legends
of man and the you know the impossibly
great man of magnificence you know the
groups that i'm talking about they all
have these like fancy titles
and you know you'll see some guy in
there and he's like hey fellas uh i want
to get some feedback on this been
married for 15 years two kids blah blah
blah uh wife isn't intimate with me
anymore you know what do i do
and then you know
the comments start to chime in and saw
well just be yourself or if you do the
dishes more and put away the laundry
then you know you'll probably get some
place you know sort of thing
and
they don't generally get good advice nor
do they give good advice to others um
they are plugged into society's lives
these are the blue pill condition guys
right
um another thing that you'll notice that
they'll do a lot of is they'll try to
negotiate desire and use chore play
which i just kind of described earlier
which is like you know putting away the
dishes in the laundry and taking care of
the kids so she can go up for a girls
night and that's that's not going to
generate genuine burning desire um i
think the second or third chapter of my
book if you have not got it the
unplugged elf is on amazon get it
don't be a pleb don't be plugged in go
look for answers
um
are insignificant they are not
significant they are insignificant to
their inner circle to their world around
them to the people they work with uh to
where they go about things they're and
and not everybody can be significant
okay not not it it's not like we're ever
gonna shift this bottom eighty percent
of blissfully ignorant plugged in beta
males to become unplugged alphas is just
not going to happen most of society will
remain all i'm doing is i'm giving you
these four different quadrants so you
understand the differences and then you
can you know if you if you intend to
level up or if you intend to go through
the unplugging process to become you
know the best version of yourself and
you can take those steps again these are
these these bullet points here
essentially are describing to you what
it is that you know you're sitting at
right now
okay
blah blah blah uh physically out of
shape
the
i don't know what the number is now
today but last i heard is something
between two thirds and three quarters of
the north american population is either
categorically obese
fat morbidly obese somewhere in that
area basically their body mass index or
their body fat percentage is at a place
where they're unhealthy
they generally have the comorbidities
diabetes cardiovascular disease all that
good stuff tying in with the obesity you
know sore joints bad and easy you know
they're out of breath just walking
upstairs and this could be a 25 year old
guy like i've you know i've seen this in
all age groups but they're generally
speaking also physically out of shape
plugged in betas get themselves to that
point because they don't prioritize
self-care okay it's only guys that have
unplugged that recognize the importance
of putting themselves first putting
their physique and their and their
health you know i.e self-care as a
priority
moving on they're fragile and allow
problem women in their lives now when i
talk about fragility
i'm making reference to
um the book anti-fragile you have three
categories you have uh fragile robust
and anti-fragile essentially
when chaos or stress
comes the way of plugged in betas
they basically
their stress levels go out of control
cortisol spikes you know would generally
spike in their blood panel if you were
pulling blood labs around that time but
the fragility of things coming their way
really really affect them in a negative
way i'm going to deal with the
anti-fragility part when i get to the
unplug alpha part but
problem women are another issue for them
and they routinely invite them into
their lives
if you want to learn more about
where's my link here on the banner
here it is
if you want to learn more about
red flags and the kind of problem women
that most plugged in betas invite into
their lives you should get on my email
list it's down below which is
entrepreneursandcards.com four slash red
dash flags i very rarely send out emails
maybe like once every month or two and
if i do it's of something of some
importance that you definitely want to
check out or i can't publish it on my
youtube channel i did a
um i added a probably about the eighth
or ninth email to that list uh yesterday
and it's a really really important video
that i think that you guys should check
out it's basically a documentary on
what's going on in the world today with
um the situation with the beer bug
world world finance and everything kind
of tied into that excuse me so i got to
take a step
so make sure you check that out
you don't even have to buy my book if
you want to read the chapter on red
flags it's there for free just get on
the list and then you can download it
it's a pdf
i break down the 20 red flags plugged in
betas will allow these problem women
into their life that just what they do
uh they complicate life and justify why
they do it often as nice guys i
shouldn't have to explain that i've
talked about that many times they
believe the mainstream media and vote
for big government and control the
reason why
i mean using canada is a recent example
because we just completed a election
cycle back in september
the reason why
justin trudeau continues i think he's
it's been three terms now the reason why
he continues to stay in office is
because a large popul a large chunk of
the population continues to believe
their narratives and falls for the
mainstream media lies and keep voting
for big government because they trust
them that's what plugged in betas do
that's why you're never going to see
uh a libertarian government it's just
never going to happen because the vast
majority of the population men included
subscribe to the big lies and the
mainstream area and they like the
control they don't want freedom they
want free they want big daddy
government take care of them they want a
ruler okay that's what these plugs and
betas do
uh they can also be very very successful
leaders and entrepreneurs you know i've
talked about this before um on my
channel and some prior collabs
but these but but this large chunk of
the population the 80 of guys out there
uh are basically useful puppets and
they're and they can fall into very very
successful roles i mean
there's a large number of very
successful entrepreneurs there are seven
eight nine ten figure
guys that are still plugged in betas but
they figured out how to make serious
money there's a lot of them out there
you